[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Serge Lachapelle,
and for the past 10 years,
I've been a product
manager at Google.
I'm based out of
a country called
Sweden, which apparently is very
popular around here these days.
[LAUGHS] I've had the amazing
opportunity to be part
of a journey, and--
throughout these 10 years.
And this journey, of course,
wasn't done only by myself,
but with many
colleagues that are here
in the room with me today and
for the duration of those 10
years.
So for everyone, please wave.
There you go.
And some-- I'll
invite them upfront,
those that can help in
answering your questions later.
So a bunch of the
people here in the room
have helped build what I'm
going to present here today.
Let's take a look back
at 2007, 10 years ago.
A decade feels like a longer
time than if you say 10 years.
And can anyone here
in the room tell me
something that happened in 2007?
Do you remember?
The iPhone.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: George Bush.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Yeah,
George Bush, another good one.
My son reminded me, it
was the last Harry Potter
book was published then.
But what I thought of
as well was the iPhone.
And if you look at
the iPhone today,
you can see that a
lot of the design
aspects of the
iPhone in 2007 have
kept, which is a true
hallmark of the design,
but we all know that
behind the scenes,
the services that power, the
infrastructure that power all
the software, all the hardware,
has changed tremendously.
And that made me think of
Google in 2007, when I joined.
And this is how the home
page greeted you in 2007.
And the font's a bit dated.
The logo, we know, has changed.
But if I was to
switch to 2017, you'll
notice that even the
same words are used--
Advertising, business, About,
Privacy Terms, Settings.
The layout-- the I Feel
Lucky is still there,
the microphone's new,
but things have--
things have been
fairly consistent.
But as we all know,
Google, behind the scenes,
has changed a lot,
as well, in 10 years.
And if we look at how
Google was in 2007, well,
Google had just gone from
being 3,000 employees in 2004
to 17,000 employees
by the end of 2007.
So when I joined,
I joined at a--
just at the cusp of a
period of extreme growth.
And today, Google is
about 71,000 employees--
that was end of year 2016.
And what was different
about how Google grew
was that Google grew globally.
And we didn't just open
offices in countries
for having a sales presence.
We opened offices to have
an engineering presence.
And so back in
2007, we already had
42 offices across the world,
and not just sales presence
in the countries to
do local business,
but engineering presence.
So Google was one of the-- is
one of the few companies that
really invested in a
global engineering presence
from very early on.
Talent was global.
We wanted products to be
made closer to our users
and have that input,
so it's really
helped at building a very
diverse engineering workforce.
So there we were in all these
offices, company growing,
and everyone very ambitious
to build great products
and to transform the world,
and to change the world.
But we couldn't do it
the traditional way.
The traditional way of
doing global engineering
means very heavy processes, very
long planning cycles, things
that you can't change on a whim.
And maybe I should have
showed concrete instead
of a bunch of wires tangled.
The word "process," in my
head, always means this.
But we wanted to be able
to work globally, but still
be creative, be
innovative, be agile.
You will hear that word
often in engineering.
We tried these guys--
we tried the phone.
Every employee had a phone
bridge number and a PIN.
We hated it.
It was bad quality.
It was hard to know when
it's your turn to speak.
There's no queues.
How do you know when it's
your turn to come in?
You have these long,
awkward silences,
and it was just too hard
to understand people,
and it didn't promote
creativity at all.
And then I took a snapshot
of my inbox last night, and--
maybe I don't need to
explain too much here,
but email is great.
We overuse email.
We get overloaded by email.
It's sometimes hard to
get answers quickly,
and it's also very hard
to understand each other.
And when you're a global
workforce, spoken speech,
written speech, tone,
what you actually mean,
how people perceive
what you mean
gets tricky in written form.
And so while we
got far with email,
it didn't carry us to our goals.
So one thing caught
on at Google.
And very early on,
video conferencing
seemed like a great way
to distribute a workforce.
It seemed like a great way to
promote agility, creativity,
and to build that team feeling.
So Google's founders, really
early on, decided to go for it,
and they went for
it in a big way.
Google started to deploy
Tandberg's video conferencing
units across the world.
Here's how a room
looked like in 2007.
This was a typical Google room.
This one was from
our Zurich office.
And you can see
the mess of wires
on the table, the camera
bolted to the wall.
All of the technology
was in the black cupboard
there on the left
side of the screen.
I don't know what
was in the fridge
next to it, that
little gray fridge,
but let's just say it was water.
[LAUGHS]
But a room like this
would cost anywhere
between $40,000 and $80,000
in equipment and installation
costs.
Remember, every time
someone has to come up
with a drill, that's when
the installation costs start
to climb--
to climb heavily.
But we had a lot of these units.
By the end of 2007, we
had over 2,400 rooms
like this around the world.
And these were powered
by infrastructure--
complex, on-premise
infrastructure.
And this was not for
the faint of heart.
On the left side of the
screen, you'll see a MCU.
This is where all these
rooms would connect into.
Every one of these--
an MCU, by the way, is a
Multipoint Control Unit,
but it's really a bridge.
It's something that mixes all
the video and audio together.
And we had a massive mix of
these MCUs, these gatekeepers,
these failover gatekeepers,
these border controllers,
to allow meetings with external,
outside of Google, meetings.
And as I said, this was
not for the faint of heart.
Every one of these MCUs could
connect 480 rooms dialing in,
each room using up one port.
Each port cost $4,000 if you
wanted to have 720p video.
We got really good at this.
Imagine being able
to deploy 2,400
of these rooms-- the world's
biggest Tandberg deployment,
not only in the amount
of rooms deployed,
but the amount of minutes used.
The systems were used
around the clock.
We used them to
have team meetings.
We used them to have our
Scrums, or our agile standups.
Using video
conferencing informally
became a part of our culture
because these systems
were everywhere.
And yes, you even got
to meet your boss, who
was around the world
somewhere else every week,
and look him in the
eyes, or look her
in the eyes, every
day, if you wanted.
So slowly but surely,
VC made Google
more nimble on a global scale.
And then we broke it.
We had to go and
ruin a great thing.
We ruined it because it
couldn't grow with us.
We had reached the
maximum capacity of what
a system like this could do.
And we tried, but people
wanted to dial in from home.
The software that we used
to dial in from home--
it was written by the
same people that had
written those conference rooms.
Those conference
rooms were connected
with dedicated ethernet.
They had a dedicated
part of the network.
They had quality of
service monitoring.
When you're at home, on your
home Wi-Fi or your DSL line,
the conditions are
completely different.
So software couldn't just--
just couldn't connect properly.
The calls would get dropped.
The audio, the
video were horrible.
Everyone dialing from
home would use up
one of those $4,000 ports.
So then you'd have 15
people dialing in from home,
and if there's no
more ports available,
it means your 20-person
room that you just
paid $80,000 to install
couldn't connect to the meeting,
because all the home folks
would compete with them.
These were real issues.
I remember these bridges--
I remember one of
them catching fire.
And we knew-- everyone knew how
expensive those things were.
Everyone knew that Google just
had meetings, after meetings,
after meetings.
So I remember-- this
could be a legend,
but I remember a Google
field tech having oven mitts,
pulling out a card that was
on fire to save the bridge,
instead of going at it
with an extinguisher.
That's dedication.
And again, if one of
those cabinets filled up,
and you only had
four ports left,
and you had a 10-person meeting,
things would fail inexplicably.
I also remember having
to have engineers
from the various companies
we were buying products
from on site in California.
And they were at our offices
for very long periods of time,
probably charging by the hour.
And I'll always remember
them, because they were always
the ones renting the fancy
rental cars at the airport--
you know, the big orange--
or the big orange Mustang
that's always there?
And it says, it could be
yours for $150 more a day.
These engineers that we
were flying in to help us,
they would always drive
the fancy Mustangs.
And they would work,
and work, and work
at trying to get
our system to scale.
And we couldn't get there.
So what happened?
We decided that it
was time to innovate.
So Google-- back then,
the management team
was called the
Operating Committee.
And they made an
important decision.
They said, we're not going
to buy this stuff anymore.
It's done.
It's over.
Google is going to go from
17,000 employees to much,
much more, and
we're probably going
to grow quicker than what
these systems can offer anyhow.
We need to build at scale.
And this means that
the pressure was on.
So what follows is a
bit of storytelling
about how different
innovation tracks happened--
some simultaneously,
some serially,
and some building off
on top of each other.
The first one was
to build for scale.
So here is video chat in Gmail.
Let's see if we
can get some audio.
I did this video
in November 2008--
took me eight hours.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Ah!
There you are.
Hi, I'm Serge, and I help
develop Gmail voice and video
chat from Sweden.
Our team works closely
with the team in the US,
so video chat comes
in really handy.
Some things are just better
communicated face-to-face,
where you can see
expressions, gestures,
and I can point things
out on a diagram.
Plus, whenever I travel,
I get to see my kids.
So let me show you
how this works.
Gmail voice and video chat is
integrated right into Gmail,
so it's very easy to use.
To start a voice or
video chat, simply click
on the "Video & more" link at
the bottom of the chat window.
When a person receives a
call, they'll hear a ring,
and they'll see a notification
that they can choose to answer.
You can pop out the chat
window and adjust the size
and positioning as you like.
You can even make it go full
screen through a single click.
It's free and easy to use.
Visit gmail.com/videochat
to get started.
[END PLAYBACK]
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
If ever someone
asks you to volunteer
for something like that,
think twice.
[LAUGHS] What's important here--
so I had been working with
software video conferencing
for 10 years.
So I started around '97.
And we had a small
company, and in 10 years,
we were able to get 200,000
users, and we were all proud.
When we launched this
thing, the 200,000 user mark
passed in a few hours.
It is amazing, the scale
at which Google operates.
And having all these users, with
all these different firewall
settings, and all these
different networks,
and all these different
cameras and audio card,
and trying to support all of
them was an amazing challenge.
But we learned a ton from it.
So building at that
scale helped us
understand how to cater to
many, many, many scenarios.
Let's see if I can
go forward here.
Oh, I'm on-- sorry about that.
I need to click on the
white area-- perfect.
Oops.
So we started with Gmail video
chat, and then we went to--
oops, the video started
playing in the background.
Please don't make me
hear myself again.
[LAUGHS] And this was all fine--
one-on-one conversations--
but we wanted to replace
the Tandberg experience.
We wanted to give
group video meetings.
So we have an engineer in
Sweden and a UX designer
who was based out of our
Kirkland office, Jake Knapp--
they had been thinking
a lot about this.
And it was pretty obvious very
quickly that we wouldn't be
able to do full-blown group
video conferencing inside
of Gmail, so we did a little--
we did a little
sandbox play area
where we started to play with
the software in different ways.
And these two individuals
came to the epiphany
that, hey, why don't we
just tie and actual meeting,
or a meeting room, to a URL?
And so we built a prototype,
and we called it go/meet,
and we'd say, hey,
let's go meet in foo--
go/meet/foo.
And that caught on, and people
thought, hey, this is neat.
Great.
And this led to
something called go/meet
that we were using
internally at Google in 2009.
And this is another prototype.
Arthur has not aged--
lucky him.
And you'll see, some other
people on that screen
are in the room with us today.
And we launched this to Google
in 2009, and it became--
it picked up.
It became a big success.
People could work from home.
The latency was a lot lower
than those video bridges
that had to transcode.
There was no transcoding
in this system.
And people could take
meetings from their desk.
They could take
meetings from home.
meetings on the road.
And so there was a moment where
this started to grow quicker,
and the Tandberg rooms were
being used less and less.
And this became Google
Hangouts a little bit later on.
One thing that was different
with this back in 2009
is, video was on by
default. You went
into a meeting, go/meet
hangout, or go/meet/foo,
and video was on.
And that was an important pillar
for this software experience,
because if all these
people would join,
and you'd all be
sort of avatars,
and be audio only, who's
the first person to dare
show themselves on camera in
front of all these others,
right?
Who's that conceited
person that's
going to be the first one
to say, hey, I'm so great,
I'm going to show
myself for everyone.
And so those
systems didn't work.
The ones that didn't
have video on by default,
straight from the
start, they don't
work for building team culture.
This created a sense of team.
And after a few
times, you don't care
about your hair or the mess the
kids made in the background,
because this is your team.
This is your safe space.
These are the people
you create with.
This is a people you
build software with.
Our second innovation
track was about the stack.
Building video
communication software
was a real pain back then.
You had to license
third-party software.
Not just surf
third-party technology,
but a third-party audio stack,
a third-party video stack.
And then you had the
fun part of taking
two different technologies
from two different companies,
put them on top of
your own network stack,
and then fit this
into a plug-in.
Remember, the plug-in
architecture is called NPAPI.
The N stands for Netscape.
Just, this is something
people forget.
And you needed the plug-in
for Mac, Windows, and Linux.
And you needed to
have a great flow
for deploying these
plug-ins, but also
for keeping them updated.
So how do you update a plug-in?
How do you download the plug-in
so it doesn't affect the call?
How do you update the plug-in
so you don't tear down
a call that's going on?
And how do you do
that in a browser
without the actual software
page being showed up,
because that's usually
where these things would
get triggered?
Very tricky, and with one
of the best install flows
that you could find
on the internet,
we still had first
attempts to join a meeting
failures of about 30%.
People just cannot-- it's just
too hard to download software
on your desktop, and find
that file, run the installer,
complete the installer,
remember to restart the browser,
because this is a plug-in.
People would fail at joining
their meetings the first time.
All this complexity
of deployment,
and having to integrate other
people and other companies'
technology, meant that
innovation stagnated,
and quality was a
hard thing to improve,
when you're not in
control of your own stack.
So a team at Google started
a project called WebRTC.
WebRTC is an open-source
audio and video platform
that developers can
use to create video
and audio communication apps.
It's available on
Chrome, Android, and iOS,
and there's other browsers
that take the code
and implement it in
their own browsers.
It's an open-source
community effort
with different standard bodies.
It's highly secure.
And in Chrome, this is
a one-click experience.
There's no more download.
You click, and you're
in your meeting.
That helped a lot of users.
And it's not a stretch
of the imagination
to say that WebRTC,
today, powers video
conferencing on the internet.
If you use Google Hangouts,
Google Duo, Facebook Messenger,
GoToMeeting, Twilio, the list
of companies is over 1,000 long,
of companies that
integrate WebRTC,
the code that Google
wrote and Google
made available
for creating web--
for creating video
conferencing experiences.
So now we had started
building software.
Then we decided that we
wanted to own the stack.
We wanted to understand
how audio and video works.
We wanted to make
that part better.
But we still had
Google Chrome growing
like crazy in all these
meeting rooms that needed
videoconferencing support.
And so this is a video
of two of my colleagues,
Steve [INAUDIBLE]
and Eric [INAUDIBLE]
We bought a HP
TouchSmart in 2008,
and that's the one we bought.
This ran Windows Vista.
It ran Firefox and something
called Greasemonkey,
if any of you remember this.
It would grab the video
chat little bubble
that you saw in
that video, and it
would make it big so that you
didn't know Gmail was there
in the background.
And with the touch
screen, it allowed
you to punch in a meeting name.
It cost $1,000, $1,050,
instead of several thousands
of dollars.
There were no remote
controls or devices.
This was an all-in-one.
And so this was
our first attempt
at creating a video conferencing
room setup by ourselves.
Oh, I will--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- --with Eric [INAUDIBLE],
who's also filming.
- Hi.
We're working on the
[INAUDIBLE] project
to kiosk a PC to function
as a Tandberg replacement.
So I'm going to go
ahead and power it on.
As soon as you hit dial,
it will go directly
to this page that will show
you a video conference that you
will join in progress.
- This was one of the
first times it all worked.
- Let's see if anyone's there.
Calling--
- Ta-da.
- Just like talk video.
[END PLAYBACK]
SERGE LACHAPELLE:
And that was it.
The actual meeting-- the actual
video was like 15 minutes
long, because it was
powered by Vista,
and it took so
much time to boot.
But so, you know, the team
did-- there was so much
work that needed to be
done after this first proof
of concept, right?
We moved this to Linux,
we redid the front end,
we had to do fleet
management on this
so that we-- because we wanted
to deploy thousands of these.
But that little video,
those two individuals
and the others that worked
with them, led to a revolution
at Google.
We built a video
conferencing appliance.
And so this is today at Google.
And all of our meeting rooms
have video conferencing.
And they're all built on
top of the same software
that I just talked about,
Hangouts and WebRTC.
It's powered by
computers that run--
that run ChromeOS today.
We're going to talk about
that in a little minute.
But we've got over
15,000 rooms today
that have video
conferencing capabilities.
So this is one of the
offices in Tel Aviv.
Here is an office in London.
This is a smaller huddle room.
And this is how good we've
become at choosing the cables,
passing the cabling--
the amount of
discipline and thought
that has gone
through all of this
is just staggering, because
when you have to do something
15,000 times across 70 offices
now, or 70 countries now,
you can't let
anything to chance.
So what cables do you use?
How do you pull the cables?
What holes do you drill?
What boxes that you choose to
insulate sound from the PC?
All those things are
really, really important.
And we put that ubiquity to use.
So today, if you look
at our usage at Google,
we've got Googlers dialing in
to a video meeting 230,000 times
a day for a company that's
about 71,000 employees.
We spend 9.2, 9.3 years of time
every day in video meetings.
And this is not just meetings.
This is, again, a team
that is distributed,
that wants to feel that
feeling of togetherness.
It's people that want
to have one-on-ones.
It's teams that want to
have their daily Scrums,
or their huddles.
And it's people that just want
to have a virtual presence.
Maybe they're working
from home that week,
and they want to feel
close to their team,
so they're just on video,
and the rest of the team
follows suit.
And again, we've got over
15,000 of these rooms
internally at Google.
And then everyone has their
laptops and their phones,
and the same experience
that they have in the room
moves to the laptop
and moves to the phone.
That's a very important
detail in this case,
because you don't want to
create islands of communication.
If you have a
different room system
than what you use on
your laptop and than what
you use on your phone, when
you try to bring all of these
together, you create
kind of separate islands
of collaboration, and the
lowest common denominator
of the experience--
you know, it just makes
everything dumbed down a lot.
And I don't know what happened,
but you see, the company,
since 2013, doubled in size.
But the video minutes in
this system have gone up 17x.
So as the company grows, you've
got this kind of social graph
that just explodes.
And people want to share
experiences, share knowledge,
and just make sure that
everyone is up to date.
And the whole company can make
decisions quicker thanks to it.
And I think this is what makes
Google one of the-- a unique
company, because we can
do global engineering,
and I think you can
see it taking off now.
There is a fourth
track to all of this,
and it's a little product
called Chromebox for Meetings.
The same team that built
the beautiful deployments
that you saw a few years
ago understood that ubiquity
was very important.
They wanted to be able
to scale things up
to much more than 15,000 rooms.
I've heard a rumor that
there's expectations
that we had an extra 20,000
rooms over the next two years
to our system.
And that team
understood very quickly
that having a computer, having
to pass all these wires,
maybe was a level
of complexity that
was too high to be able to
scale up to those numbers.
So that team sat
down and created
a system that would also
cater to our customers' needs,
because our customers have as
large deployments as we do.
Some of our customers beat
us in the amount of minutes
they do per employee out there.
It's incredible to see the
power of ubiquitous video
conferencing and what
it brings to a company.
A ChromeOS machine
that is secure--
there is nothing more secure
than a ChromeOS computer
on the market today
because of the way
the hardware is signed into
the software and vice versa.
A computer that allows you
to do remote management of it
very easily.
And this is why Chromebooks
are so popular in schools
and in enterprise, because
of this remote management
capabilities.
A computer that connects
to your calendar,
to your room's calendar, and
all it does all day is it
shows your room's calendar,
and it's waiting for a click.
Its just sitting there
waiting for a click.
And when someone clicks,
boom, you're in the meeting.
And that's about the amount
of interaction it gets.
When you share-- when
you want to share
a document to your
meeting, you do it
over Wi-Fi from your computer.
You can mute yourself,
you can hang up the call,
and you can start the call.
And everything comes
from Google Calendar.
So it integrates really
well with G Suite.
And we really believe
that this is the next step
to our ubiquity project.
And we're working really
hard at evolving this,
not only for growing Google's
video conferencing culture,
but also bringing our customers
with us on the journey.
So expect a lot of great things
on this front a little bit
later this year.
So finally, today, you
could say that thanks
to all this work, and all
this innovation, and 10 years
of sweat and tears, we've
been able to support a video--
a global engineering culture
that fits into what Google is.
It spans the globe.
It saves time.
It helps Google make
decisions quickly.
It helps people share
ideas, help each other,
and be able to try to reach
some kind of work-life balance.
If you need to work from
home, you work from home.
There's no need to
commute in every day.
And now, this is a
tool that is evolving
based on your
feedback and the input
that you've been
giving us as customers.
And you might wonder what
happened to our Tandberg
systems.
And when I was looking
at this last night,
I found a web page from
a team in Australia
that recycled them and created
PlayStation 4 kiosks with them.
And apparently, the
shape of the PS4
fit perfectly in that
cabinet, and they
became very popular
in certain countries
as PlayStation 4 enablers.
So on that, thanks
for listening.
[MUSIC PLAYING]